that's they discuss politics the media
and campaign 96 this is the first of a
two-day conference where women discussed
their I would like to welcome a woman
who is known probably to many of you
here in the room and that is Lynne
Cheney Lynne Cheney is currently a
senior fellow at the American Enterprise
Institute for Public Policy Research
this is an independent nonpartisan
organization sponsoring original
research on domestic and international
economic policy foreign and defense
policy and social and political issues
perhaps Lynne Cheney was best known as
chairman of the National Endowment for
the Humanities a post she held from 1986
through 1992 mrs. Cheney is a prolific
writer her articles have appeared in the
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
the Washington Post the Christian sign
Science Monitor among others she has
written several books with her husband a
guy you may know Dick Cheney mrs. Cheney
holds a PhD in English and has taught at
several colleges and as I'm sure many of
you have met her or know her well
without further ado Lynne Cheney
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you very much what a
privilege to be here with so many
leaders who happen to be women I can't
tell you how nice it is to be in a room
full of people who will want to hear
what I have to say I spend much of my
life on college campuses which fully
prepared me for my current a job as the
co-host of weekend crossfire because
often when I go to college campuses what
what I have to say is not especially
loved by the faculty I will tell you
though it is very much appreciated by
many of the students and as I see it
that's one of the reasons that we can
expect what we saw happen in 1994
continue we do have so many young people
to completely understand the importance
of what we emphasized in 1994 who are
convinced that it is important that we
really balance the budget who are
convinced that it is important that we
really rein in big government who are
convinced that it is important that we
emphasize the core values that have made
this country great particularly honesty
particularly truthfulness let me just
tell you one little anecdote and I will
tell you I'm a little bit of a time
filler here we're waiting for one of our
pollsters who hasn't arrived but I was
at a college in the in the Middle West
and what was worcester college i don't
need to be hesitant about the name of
this particular institution and they had
received much publicity for having a
terribly pc campus and for only inviting
liberal speakers so what happened to me
is what happens to me frequently i was
invited as the token conservative i mean
it's not bad if you if you're gonna get
invited for any reason at all you get a
chance to present your message you
should probably be appreciative my
subject lately has been telling the
truth i had a book come out in october
on on this topic and i took up all sorts
of
issues in which we have fallen in our
society into being relativistic into
saying well there's no such thing as
truth there's only your way of looking
at it in my way of looking at it and I
talk in this book about how this new
attitude manifests itself and everything
from our history books where we recently
saw this big fuss about the national
history standards trying to present a
view of our history to our children that
made it seem as though the unluckiest
thing that could happen to a human being
was to be born in the United States of
America it is a country or so these new
standards presented a country in which
everything bad has happened not very
much good has happened and surely some
sort of great social upheaval is
necessary in order for us to save
ourselves a social upheaval that would
surely do away with capitalism that was
one of the great failings as these
history standards pointed it out but
also of course has become an issue in
politics and I had a chapter in my book
about the first postmodern president and
I guess I won't have to think that this
group will not know whom I was speaking
about if there is an example of this
postmodern view of there being no single
truth but only different views that we
express with various degrees of
conviction surely Bill Clinton is the
best example that we have seen of that I
think in in the modern era talking about
his presidency viewing the future of the
nation as a time when the era of big
government is over is so outrageous it
is quite amazing to me that when he said
this in his State of the Union speech
that there weren't gasps across the
nation that some sort of seismic shift
didn't occur when he said such a thing
and of course you can go through his
presidency and see the shifts on policy
we've seen it lately when he says he
wants to reform welfare that's the
rhetoric that's the view of reality he
tries to convince
up what does he do when he gets a very
good welfare bill sent to him he vetoes
it we saw it on Securities Litigation
Reform you know what this is this is an
attempt to overcome the lawyers
particularly in California who go after
small businesses who go after CEOs for
saying that they think their business is
heading in one direction and then lo and
behold it doesn't
none of us of course are able to predict
the future fully and so they would be
sued for having misled the stock holders
and inevitably they would settle because
the cost of defending themselves was so
great perfectly good Securities
Litigation Reform bill came out of the
Congress Bill Clinton said this is a
good idea we need to reform this had
dinner with a friend of his who was
important in the Trial Lawyers
Association which is given 2.5 million
dollars to his campaign in the first
eight months of 1995 changes mine and
vetoed the bill fortunately it was
overridden by Congress and then just
lately we saw we saw the the reform bill
that he vetoed last week the bill that
would reform product liability the bill
that is making it hard for children who
have to have shunts because of
hydrocephaly to get those shunts the
bill is not the bill is aimed at fixing
this situation these little kids who
need silicone shunts to divert the fluid
building up in their brains are having
trouble getting the shunts because the
silicon manufacturers are so terrified
of litigation this is a bill that would
have fixed this problem the president
says the problem he's fixing but of
course he he vetoed the bill even the
Washington Post is saying Clinton talks
one way Bill Clinton talks the moderate
talk and this was in their in their
editorial page yesterday it's the most
amazing thing he talks one way he talks
the moderate talk but when it comes time
to sign or veto a bill when it comes
time to do that he aligns himself with
the traditional Democratic
constituencies the people who don't want
reform
well I talked about politics in my book
I talked about a number of things but I
do want to tell you this story from the
Midwest college because it's a it is so
heartening I talked about the truth and
I always try to say early on in my
speech I don't know what it is and I
don't suspect any of you know what it is
but I do know that this country has
achieved greatness by our assuming that
we should try to work toward it by our
assuming that our goal is to try to get
there our goal isn't to try to fool the
American people or to fool ourselves our
goal is to try to get to the truth and I
try to say that early on in a speech
just so people won't think that I
arrogantly think that I know what is
true and good and write well in this
speech I didn't so one of the students
at the end and students are so smart
raised his hand and said ok mrs. Cheney
you tell me what to choose this so then
I had a chance to give my little speech
about it and say I don't know what the
truth is and I don't think you do either
but this student was very persistent and
bright and he said well all right mrs.
Cheney if you don't know what the truth
is and I don't know what the truth is
who do you think knows what the truth is
and I said well I don't mean to give a
religious speech I'm here in a secular
occasion but I think God knows what the
truth is that kind of silence settled
over and there wasn't much fuss or
anything but after the speech I was
surrounded by students who said you know
that's the first time God has been
mentioned in a public occasion on this
campus well what an amazing thing these
kids are wonderful these kids are good
these kids are bright and they're the
future for all of us dick and I've
written a new book and we were on Tim
Russert show this weekend I just watched
it last night
and I and one of my husband's biggest
fans and sometimes I think the reason I
so enjoy listening to him is that he
always surprises me I don't know what
he's gonna say and when he says
something it will just turn on a light
bulb for me and in a very interesting
way and Tim Russert asked me what the
odds were the Republicans would lose
control to Congress
and I said you know I just answered the
question directly I said I would say one
in four no more than that
no less than that there's always a
chance and I would say it's one in four
and then he turned to dick and asked the
question and it gave such a more
interesting answer
he said you know I don't know Tim but I
can tell you this is one of the most
important elections in our lifetime it
may be the most important election in
our lifetime and I knew exactly what he
meant because it's this election that is
going to determine whether we head in
the direction of a balanced budget or
whether we continue to let federal
spending run amok placing a huge burden
on our children and our grandchildren it
will determine whether the era of big
government is really over or whether we
just played lip service to that idea and
continue to let it grow and grow and
intrude in our lives and it will
determine whether whether we align
ourselves as a nation with those core
values like truth-telling or whether we
move in another direction in which the
award goes to the most deceitful in
which the award goes to those who are
most able to fool the American people in
which the award goes to those who are
good at campaigning and not much
concerned about the real process of
governing so this is an important panel
I want to learn from it I know you do
too we have three people here with us
today two are they all here now three
people here with us today who can give
us something of a roadmap I think I
always think of polls as a chance to see
where you are as a chance to let you
know how to get where you want to be
they aren't predictors of the future of
course none of us are but we have some
of the brightest most intelligent people
here with us today to give us some
notion of how this election how we can
make what is going to be the most
important election of our lifetime
turnout in the way that we want it to so
a few three would join me on the stage I
think the best way for us to proceed is
for me to introduce you one by one for
each of you to talk
four five six seven minutes and then I
know that you and I would like to learn
from this audience and have a chance to
hear from them their questions and and
your answers so since I know Linda de
Val the best like I don't have a list
here of what order we're supposed to go
in but Linda and I have been in
Washington together for a very long time
um I think I'll have Linda go first let
me just tell you a little bit about her
she is uh recognized as as are the other
two pollsters with us today is one of
the bright rising young stars not just
in the Republican Party but in the
community of political analysts and
Linda has been involved in some of the
most influential campaigns I just let me
give you a short list here Newt Gingrich
dick lugar Fred Thompson
Nancy Johnson Tilly flour Jim Nussle
Mike Oxley Sonny Bono the list goes on
and on linda has has had a great impact
in our in our city you see her
frequently on television I am always so
impressed with her when I do she has
that ability that I just spoke about
Diggs having a minute ago she doesn't
say anything predictable or it's not
predictable you know you really learn
every time every time oh and it speaks
so with that really big buildup Linda
would you uh would you like to give us a
few minutes on I know the gender gap has
been something you've been concerned
about Thank You Ellen as a pollster you
learn out to be too predictable all the
time therefore you have some cover it's
I'm sure Killian and Frank can attest to
I have an immense challenge here tonight
to try to go through what I want to say
without the benefit of using any
overheads which is a first for me but
but I want to focus on I'm not certain
personally what Frank and Kellyanne are
going to be looking at but I want to
focus on a couple things number one the
current political environment where we
stand today number two obviously a brief
assessment of the gender gap but three
some distinctions between registered and
non registered women in a survey that we
just conducted with cylinder Lake a
Democrat poster on behalf of the Ladies
Home Journal and I think it offers us an
excellent
assessment of a potential group of
voters that are indeed available to us
and as Republicans while I agree with
with Chris's sentiment that Bob bill
certainly should be elected at the
election were held today he would not be
elected and I think one of the things
that's incumbent upon us in this room
and why we are pollsters the three of us
is to try to change the dynamic of what
does that work today there is certainly
no reason why Bill Clinton should be
reelected
what we need to do is to change this
election and make it a referendum on the
incumbent and we have been a little bit
negligent in that task or the course of
the past five months I couldn't help but
reading the The New York Times The
Washington Post this weekend both
Saturday and Sundays paper it was quite
interesting to see that Bob Dole
apparently gave the speech that many of
us have been hoping that he would give
for quite some time where he said on
five different times the reason I want
to be elected president is because and
address five specific reasons of what he
would do in the New York Times it was
not covered whatsoever in the Washington
Post they paid exactly one paragraph
attention to that speech instead that
was drowned out by some of the comments
that Senator D'Amato made in terms of
his own the election prospects in New
York that's the type of you know that's
what we need to overcome that's a
challenge that we need to overcome is
the filter of the press and that's why
it's very important that all of us in
this room leave here after the course of
the next couple days and go back and
have charged to take on the mission at
hand first of all the gender gap does
indeed still exist it is alive and well
but before I get to that let me just
report on a couple of other things or a
number of factors that tend to
contribute to the gender gap that one is
the belief by women that we should
indeed have a more activist government
women look to government to answer more
of their problems many of them are
employed in the fields of government
education health care and social
services that call for the government to
be very much involved men tend tend to
have exactly the opposite reaction they
do not want to see an activist
government one of the things that I have
found most striking looking at the exit
polling data from 1990 to 94 and then a
follow-up survey question that the Wall
Street Journal NBC News did was this
very basic question should the
government do more to solve national
problems or is the government doing too
many things better left of businesses
and individuals in 1992 one of the
reasons that George Bush was defeated
was a plurality of people in this
country thought that government should
do more to solve national problems by
margin of
49 to 41% obviously if the character
issue was at play George Bush would
still be president and those of you are
counting on character to win this
election I think that is a failed
strategy because Bill Clinton is
probably the best campaigner if not
perhaps the most devious campaigner of
all time and we need to be prepared to
face that task
well we found in 1994 with the election
of majorities Republican majorities to
the house in the Senate was something
strikingly different and I think we have
Bill Clinton's health care plan to thank
for that on the same question should
government do more to solve national
problems or is government doing too many
things 56% said the government is doing
too many things better left to
businesses and individuals 41% that the
government should do more that is now up
to 60% so in spite of what we have
endured over the course of the last five
months of the Medicare campaign with
government shutdown there is still a
prevailing sense in the country today
the government frankly is doing too many
things at the national level and
certainly what most of us have seen is
that people have much more faith in
their local and state government than
they do their federal government
the other interesting thing is looking
at the issue agenda today it's still
very much reflects quite frankly what
Ross Perot brought to the forefront in
1992 when we asked people what's what
will be the most important issue is
guiding your presidential vote we find
number one balancing the budget and
cutting spending a twenty percent number
two economic growth and job creation is
17 percent and number three protecting
Medicare and Social Security at 12
percent health care reform itself is
only at 5 percent well in 1992 20
percent of all Americans and 24 percent
of all women said health care reform was
most important so health care reform has
moved on on the agenda but the concern
for Medicare frankly at 12% is
significantly higher than what we've
seen in the past and with women over 60
that increases to 28 percent so that is
an issue that is certainly creating us
some problems with that audience
improving the quality of education is at
9% and that is something that Bill
Clinton has stressed a great deal over
the course of the past five months the
Democrat campaign strategy is basically
based around the 3yz elderly education
in the environment and those are the
three issues that they tend to press
forward in terms of accentuating the
gender gap and making clear the
divisions between the two parties in
their approach to government
now we are in the field on a monthly
basis and we have some new donors from
our April survey that are frankly quite
encouraging given the fact that we have
not really engaged in a campaign with
Bill Clinton just yet and that is we
finally found for the first time about
three months that his disapproval rating
was back up to 40% and his approval
rating was at 53% now the sign of any
president who is getting in a good
position to be reelected as if he is
able to push that disapproval rating
down below 40% and sustain that Ronald
Reagan was able to do that Jimmy Carter
was unable to do that George Bush was
unable to do that so the fact that
President Clinton still is at 53 40
approve disapprove as it is indeed a
sign of vulnerability the second thing
we look at is whether people want to see
Bill Clinton re-elected or is it time
for a new person and for the first
quarter of this year we found about a
majority of people wanting to see him
reelected although it was only 50%
reelect 44 percent new person a recent
survey shows it back to being about
evenly divided 48 percent want to see
him re-elected 46 percent new person and
there are some of the predictable
differences on the gender gap on that
question for example men 46 percent of
all men say Bill Clinton should be
reelected 49 percent of all men say it's
time for a new person if you look at all
women it's 52 percent reelect a 42
percent new person now obviously there
are a lot of other distinctions with the
women's vote does all of us in this room
know and I think something that killing
in and I in particular recently
frustrated about dealing with the press
is this tendency to treat the woman's
vote as a monolithic vote when it's 53
percent of the country is very difficult
to typecast a majority of women in terms
of how they might behave for example
when we look at white working women
which is 24% of the electorate we find
on the congressional level we are dead
even with the Democrats in fact have a
1% lead 45 percent to 44 percent whereas
only 50 percent of white working women
want to see Bill Clinton re-elected and
45 percent want to see a new person but
Bob Dole trails by 15 points so clearly
there is a tendency for them to vote
Republican at the Congressional level
and at the presidential level they are
not yet doing that and I think one of
the reasons for that is the
Congressional agenda is fairly clear
what the speaker and his team wanted to
do over the course of the two-year
period was very well defined with the
American public and woman in particular
want to see a sign of leadership but I
think in the presidential level that has
not just happened yet I'll be it is
still very early in the process and we
look to see that happening in the near
future the point of that is that there
are a number of opportunities for us to
win with the women's vote the Democrats
I think are slightly misinterpreting
what is going on here they're saying
that they have they want to make 1996
the year the angry woman
you know the clever 94 0 the angry man
so this will be the year of the angry
woman I'm fighting that with all I have
because I think that is far too
simplistic and indeed not accurate the
reality of the situation is that many
women who decide not to give not to
become registered to vote do so for two
reasons more important that they're
angry at the system number one is simply
time constraints the inability to
balance you know family and job and
handle all that and be registered to
vote and the second is whether their
vote simply makes a difference or not
now one of the things I've urged our
house leaders to take a look at is go
back over our legislation over the
course of the past year and draw out
four or five things in particular that
the Republicans in Congress did to
advantage women because that story I
believe is largely untold and what the
Democrats are trying to do is they're
saying well women in 1994 stayed at home
because they were so they were just
appalled their Republican policies well
that's not really the case that's about
half the truth the real fact of the
matter is that many of those women
stayed at home because they were
primarily disillusioned with President
Clinton he came to office they had a
great deal of trust in him they thought
he was going to make things happen in
this country and bring about fundamental
change and he failed and not only did he
fail but he didn't deliver on a couple
of key promises tax relief for the
middle class and welfare reform those
two issues are still significantly
important to women and we have to
continue to make that case made as we go
through the rest of the year let me just
look at a recent survey that I alluded
to that we did feel celinda lake and
then i will turn it back over to the
rest of the pollsters this is a very
interesting survey and again I would
title this the disaffected women as
opposed to the angry woman first of all
when we interviewed a thousand women 600
were registered to vote 400 were not
registered to vote and I always think
that my middle sister Jean when I think
of the survey because in 1986
I was working at an Illinois Senate
primary and I called her back in
Wheeling Illinois and I said well gene
who's uh he was winning the primary well
I don't know I was wondering why all the
flags are up at the schools today well
my sister Jean is now the Wheeling
village clerk ran for board of trustees
last year has definitely become very
involved and she likes to tell me she is
the only elected official in the BAL
family yes so she has decided to become
involved and there were reasons for that
you know the things that she saw
happening in her local community that
she wanted to get involved be a part of
that contribute in terms of public
service and I think that is a lesson
that we see with a lot of women as they
socialize as different life excuse me as
different life circumstances happens to
them to change their point of view but
overall what we find with women is that
69 percent say things in the country
have gotten off on the wrong track only
17 percent believe things in the country
are headed in the right direction 54
percent say they're concerned and
worried about their own personal future
in the next five years and sixty nine
percent are worried and concerned about
the future of the United States over the
course of the next five years when asked
to choose a list of adjectives or
provide an adjective that would describe
their feeling about politics and
politicians two-thirds offer negative
adjectives the leading adjectives 17%
show is frustrated 16 percent shows
disgusted and 14 percent shows
disillusioned so it should be no
surprise that they have decided to tune
out and to hop from politics and I think
if we had more Jennifer Dunsmore
Barbican of [ __ ] more Tilly followers
more Deborah prices more Nancy Johnsons
and had a much broader and bigger image
of the Republican Party that that would
certainly benefit not only our party
because party perceptions are a
significant concern of mine as we move
towards the 1996 election but would
allow more women to get involved in the
party and understand our Republican
policies and principles do indeed
advantage families and individuals when
we looked at the 40% of the sample who
said they were not registered to vote we
found three key reasons why they were
not registered number one 33 percent
said it's simply a time factor number 2
23% said voting doesn't make a
difference in last 17 percent said they
were so angry that they simply did not
want to get involved
now a couple of interesting things on
the issue diamond dynamic and conclusion
here the the woman's agenda frankly is
perfectly in mesh with what we as the
Republican Party have been talking about
over the course of the last ten years
quite frankly they have a fundamental
concern for the economy and jobs that's
the most important issue concerns about
the national budget and taxes are next
at 16% crime and violence particularly
rising juvenile crime in a weakened
criminal judicial system is next at 14%
and concern for health care at 10% what
is interesting is that 56% of the woman
in the survey worry all the time about
making ends meet
52% worry all the time about having a
secure retirement 54% say they worry all
the time about taxes eating up too much
of their family's income and 53% worried
all the time about government wasting
too much of their money I ask you is
that not the Republican agenda there's
absolutely no reason why we cannot
appeal to women face quite simply on the
concerns that they are articulating to
us the last thing that we found is
important is their rankings and what's
important when they are judging a
candidate for office number one is the
candidates position on specific issues
number two is a candidate's character
and integrity and number three is the
candidates experience and abilities
again starting with Bob Dole and moving
down the rest of the Republican ticket I
think we have absolutely nothing to fear
in that regard I think that we have an
excellent opportunity to close the
gender gap remember in 1988 we were much
in the same position where George Bush
well as more like June of 88 where
George Bush trailed by about 18 points
by the time of the convention was dead
even at the conclusion of the convention
was about eight points ahead and indeed
on Election Day 1988 carried a majority
of the women's vote there is no reason
that we have to accept the gender gap
there is no reason for us to blame
others it is up to us all individually
to try to find a way to turn it around
with groups of Women Voters that are
clearly available to us and again a
thing that I resent and resist the most
is the label of calling Women Voters a
monolithic vote the Democrats are trying
to do that they are trying in a way to
say it is socially unacceptable for you
as a woman to vote Republican and I
think we're all smart enough to deny
that and figure out ways to get the
right message out
those groups of women who frankly are
not quite certain what the Democrats
will do for them and have some
disillusionment about Bill Clinton's and
ability to deliver on basic promises of
welfare reform and tax relief for
middle-class families thank you actually
worse than they're saying it's socially
unacceptable to be a Republican the
thinking is and the idea that's being
conveyed is if you are a Republican
somehow you're not a real woman one of
our most respected senators I think he
Bailey Hutchison I'm now from Texas she
is my senator I am so proud of this one
of the odder things that has ever
happened to her is that Gloria Steinem
called her a female impersonator do you
get that because nobody could be a real
woman and be a Republican so it is it is
a devastating effort to stereotype us
and with people like Linda they won't do
it very long nor with people like Kelly
Ann Fitzpatrick our next speaker who is
president of the polling company a
political analyst for CNN and most
recently was selected by campaigns and
elections magazine as a rising star of
politics you also see your on c-span on
national empowerment television in the
network news she's written for The Wall
Street Journal National Review campaigns
and elections and she was profiled in
George magazine this is you might know
is John Kennedy's efforts so the fact
that Kellyanne is breaking through even
into the Democratic consciousness is
important and she was named by the
National Journal as one of Washington's
most influential conservatives 40 and
younger so Kelly Ann Fitzpatrick please
enlighten us and tell us how to get
where we want to go
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
I did call John Kennedy a couple weeks
ago I thought I can get a discount on
those golf clubs but he didn't return
the call
anyway that happens a lot actually I
wanted to start not with my own thoughts
but I wanted to take a direct quote out
of the mouths of Judy a voter in McComb
County Michigan who we and the polling
business call a swing voter Judy is
someone who voted has voted both
Democrat and Republican in the past at
the presidential level but she wrote it
for Ross Perot in 1992 and she voted for
John Engler two years later and this is
what Judy had to say among other things
the myth was that the Republicans just
take care of the rich and the Democrats
always take care of the poor that's just
something I was raised with my parents
would tell me you have to vote Democrat
because but I've begun to change my mind
I voted Republican in the past and I
like what they have to say I think Bob
Dole can count on me this time this is
very telling because without Judy the
attempt by the Democrats to claim that
women are most concerned about abortion
that they want affirmative action
policies to stay in place and that they
they're different their differences
between the sexes are really most
pronounced and their differences of
positions on the issues and we find that
that's not true as Linda said I think
one of the greatest assaults on women
this century has been this term the
gender gap to explain that all women
think and act and vote the same that's
me squeezing all women voters almost 100
million in this country right now
eligible voters to squeeze all women
voters into a neat little box called the
gender gap is like squeezing 100
elephants into a phone booth and it's
just not going to happen I think
eventually this phone booth that the
left is trying to construct with the
woman's vote this year will probably
fall beneath its own weight recently a
journalist probably the 12th that week
to call about a story on the gender gap
my vice president asked her I'm just
curious why are you writing about this
you see that statistics like this came
out in 1994 they came out in 1992 and
polls six month before the election bare
precious little resemblance to what
eventually happened and she this
journalist sheepishly admitted that
there's really nothing else to cover so
we we promptly faxed over to her some
things that have been put out by the
Republican National Committee office of
the co-chair because there's plenty to
cover there namely and I think that
these are wonderful statistics for all
of us to try to get out because facts
and the truth Trump everything in the
end the fact is that the seventeen
female Republican members of Congress
are all in positions of either
leadership work or committee position
subcommittee positions all seventeen so
we have 100% of them according to the
RNC in leadership or key committee
positions guess how many Democrats a
female Democrats were in similar
positions in nineteen ninety-four right
before they lost control of the House
and Senate zero you have this does not
mean a okay this is zero zero so that's
up from a big whopping zero which of
course included Patricia Schroeder who's
an incumbent of twenty four years
perhaps that's why she's retiring but
she's tired of not being in a position
of leadership but we have all seventeen
in positions of leadership Democrat
Democrat recruitment and the number of
women running as Democrats is down and
in nineteen ninety-four Republican
recruitment was up and the facts were as
follows in nineteen ninety four thirty
seven percent more Republican women ran
for office than they had in nineteen
ninety-two the so-called year of the
woman which ended up being the year of
the Democratic woman but remember all
women are supposed to be Democrat so it
follows Democrats suffered a thirteen
percent decrease in female candidacies
from 92 to 94 so the difference is 50%
that's very significant because not only
are more and more
and willing to pull the lever for the
Republicans but they're willing to run
as Republicans it is that important to
them we have the Republicans have the
only female governor in the nation right
now Christy Whitman from my home state
of New Jersey and we have 12 of the 19
female lieutenant governor's our
Republicans these are significant but I
don't want to leave today without
telling you that the who bought over the
gender gap is both overstated and
frightening frost in past congressional
elections since 1980 when a former boss
of both mine and Franklin says dick
Wirthlin invented the term the gender
gap as a way to explain why Ronald
Reagan had captured more votes among men
than women in defeating President Carter
since 1980 women in their vote their
voting behavior has fluctuated very
little in six of those eight elections
women have given Democratic
congressional candidates 54 or 55
percent of their vote the high was in
1982 amid a deep of perceived deep
recession when the Democrats picked up
26 seats that year women gave Democrats
58% but it's always been it's always
been within one to two to four points
men on the other hand have jumped from
the parties they voted Republican five
times out of those last me excuse me
Democrat five times out of those last
eight and Republican three times out of
those last eight that's where you get
the the very poor very poor excuse very
tired label the angry white man in
voting in 1994 what the media really
meant to cover I think is the fact that
Bill Clinton was on the ballot in the
minds of many American female voters in
1994 and what happened to 53 million of
them is they just stayed home that was
there that was their message to Bill
Clinton they're what we call drop-off
voters they didn't turn out who they are
I think is more important than why they
didn't turn out because again if we're
going to claim that you can't treat
women monolithically then we're gonna
have to say how you should examine them
as different segments of the voting
electorate it is far more significant to
recognize that there are there is an
intra gender gap within the woman's vote
there are many if you want for
argument's sake obviously race race
plays into the differences in the way
women and men for that matter regard the
party's traditionally socioeconomic
status which combines education and
income is another one
geography is different right now we're
dead even in ballot tests among southern
women with sometimes a slight advantage
for the Republicans even though so many
of them are registered Democrats that's
significant but I think the best way to
treat the woman's vote if we must treat
it as a large bloc is to talk about
women's stations in life where they are
at different times because that combines
age that combine socioeconomic status
that combines work that combines
marriage that combines family situation
and for years we did very simply but
very accurately say the gender gap
exists as between married and single
never married women that is still true
but I think that with women marrying
later and then widows later becoming
single again and very much favoring the
Democrats at the moment that we need to
recognize there are a whole combination
of demographic and attitudinal factors
that play into the gender gap and so
looking at 20-somethings right now for
example I think if the Democrats spines
should shiver as Republican spines
should stiffen over that group because
although in polls they will still say
yes if the election were being held
today I would vote for President Clinton
in in other questions in separate
questions in the same poll among the
same young women you find that they are
not they are not very neatly falling
into the so-called liberal camp liberal
idea idealism that existed in the past
among our youngest female voters they
are concerned about pocketbook matters
they're very concerned about finding a
job where the rest elector is is
concerned about job security they are
very concerned with the lack of good
government benefits that have inured to
them over the years they don't remember
a good thing government has ever done
for them they're quite libertarians
if I may but libertarianism actually
makes them a very ripe a very ripe
voting block for the Republicans so why
then all the hoopla about the gender gap
right now it does exist women if asked a
question six months before the election
many of them are going to go into
default mode default mode answering for
many women is with the party with whom
they've been traditionally aligned which
are the Democrats and so yes I haven't
focused on the election yet but here's
yes here is my answer and that changes
over time and you usually see in a
presidential year that the summer
changes everything and I would say as as
we've watched in past elections the fact
that women right now are even willing to
give 40 42 percent of their
congressional vote actually in recent
polls by both mine and Linda's firms who
had it even a little higher the fact
that there are disapprove of the job
Clinton is doing close to four in ten of
them is significant what is more
significant is the difference between
who is responding in polls and who
eventually turns out at the polls can be
night and day and that is the difference
between art and science
right now we measure this is all about
art and Bill Clinton is a masterful
artist he seems to create one-of-a-kind
masterpieces day by day and that is
being that is being measured in the
polls day by day but all that matters on
Election Day is science
who turns out and actually votes and how
that vote goes state-by-state we are so
electoral college system and it's
winner-take-all in each state and all of
this is very significant I actually
think the gender gap exists is being
covered right now by the media for a
reason in addition to there's just
nothing else to cover just fascinating
and that is I think there's a belief
that if you build it it will come in
terms of the gender gap that if women
not if we tell women they think this way
and they behave that way then maybe just
maybe they'll perform a step for
Democrats and they'll all cast the vote
for Bill Clinton and the rest of the
Democrats down the ticket I think that
all of us sitting up here and house they
are probably have a lot more faith in
women
to think that they will do and say and
vote as they are told to the fact that
Linda pointed out the three the three
things that are most important to women
in deciding for whom to vote position on
the issues character leadership and
experience I will reiterate what Linda's
said in this in terms of this would you
rather be on our team with our strategy
or on theirs I think that is the best
question you want to pose to each other
and to other voters as the next six
months goes by because in the end those
things do matter what people perceive
with Linda that character as a strategy
as a failed one because character isn't
intangible that must be conveyed by the
candidate and observed by the voters but
it does matter to people in the end I
would posit that the millions of women
who turned out for Clinton and gore in
1992 gave him the benefit of the doubt
on all the allegations and were so angry
at the incumbent George Bush for
breaking the most famous promise in
American political history that he's not
going to get such an easy ride this time
and the evidence we have of that is what
you read in these polls and here in
these focus groups but the evidence is
also what you saw in 1994 that was about
Bill Clinton in some degree and that was
in favor of the Republican agenda in
some degree this is the first time women
like men will be voting for both the
president who was elected in 1992 and
the Congress who was elected in 1994
what they'll do remains to be seen just
gonna make a couple of comments at the
end we see right now that there's still
a large number of American women who
feel that they're unfamiliar with
Elizabeth Dole they know that she's had
a career on her own they know that they
recognize that she's been involved in
politics or policy and some of them
recognize her as having been a cabinet
secretary but they don't have the sort
of connection with who she is that they
did with Hillary Clinton I think that is
marvelous news for the Dole for
president campaign because Elizabeth
Dole and Bob Dole together as a team are
going to make the Clintons wish that
they hadn't
formed the role of a bobbin of the
modern president and first lady first as
a team when you run and then not perhaps
when you come to the White House the one
advantage ironically that Bob and
Elizabeth Dole have that the Clintons do
not is that they may now introduce
themselves for the first time as a team
to the American public there is no way
that Bill and Hillary Clinton are going
to be able to reinvent and reintroduce
themselves and so we're way past the
first or second date with the Clintons
we now decide if we want to continue
with this marriage for four more years
we constantly hear that the Republican
Party is still the party of men white
men rich men rich white men rich white
men with bad golf games and it goes on
and on and on and on and it's always
about men and I would just ask the
cameras indulgence to pan this room one
last time to sort of put that to rest
once and for all thank you
you know I spend a lot of my life
attending conferences and going to
meetings and I cannot tell you how
interesting this one is by comparison
with the most I sit through you are very
lucky to be here today I feel lucky and
I especially would like to thank our
Republican Women in Congress and and
renew for being so smart with this panel
together it is as I tried to indicate in
the introductions thus far composed of
people who are widely recognized why we
praised rising stars is the phrase that
is usually connected with their names
and of course it's connected with
Franklin's his name to a rising star
he's also been called one of America's
50 most promising leaders age 40 and
under USA Today called him one of the
most influential minds one of the nine
most influential minds in the GOP
Newsweek wrote that he was one of three
primary engineers of the 94 Republican
landslide when I get mad at the media
and it's at least seven times a day one
of the things I get mad about is the way
the contract with America has been
trashed you would not have known even
when people were saying good things
about the product liability reform bill
that went up to the president where he
vetoed it and it was a good bill you
would not have known it had any
connection with the contract with
America people were so busy trashing the
contract that they didn't point out this
essential connection well Frank Luntz
was the pollster of record for the
contract with America
I know that we can expect wisdom from
Frank not only about where we are but
about how we can continue to advance the
ideas that the contract put forward in
such an important way thanks
first off I must apologize for my tie
apparently it's been infected with mad
cow disease as a 34 year old bachelor I
must admit that this is my dream speech
of all time if you're somewhere under
age 40 and not married you should see me
if you're over age 50 with a 20 year old
or older daughter you should see me and
I'll even date grandkids if they're old
enough I'm not here basically to pander
to you the gender gap is a gender gap it
is a real gap in fact it is a chasm it
is huge and if we sit there and say if
we excuse it or we say it doesn't exist
we don't deal with it I have a tendency
to make people that I come speak to very
angry and I don't care because if I can
shake you up just a little bit I will
I'm not going to pander to this group I
mean you don't want to waste your time
with that there are ways to deal with it
look the fact is that we've got a
president who is the ultimate
communicator of all time he feels your
pain and he feels your pain and he's
causing Lin Cheney's pain but he feels I
mean this guy emotes he's so
compassionate he's so he's so caring do
you remember the in fact he's so
confident now I understand he started
dating again
[Laughter]
[Music]
to understand
go back to that MTV special back I guess
was 2 or 3 years ago and that young
woman I think she was about 17 years old
and she stood up and she looked they're
so pleased as punch and said mr.
president briefs or boxers remember what
his actual response to that question was
what his actual words were usually
boxers usually even an underwear the guy
equivocates so so how we're gonna hold
him accountable
he said I believe back in 1992 that
women understood exactly what he was and
they understood exactly what Hillary
Clinton was and we talk about a gender
gap
look at how males and females look at
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton is still
a role model to women aged 18 to 34 but
she's absolutely hated among men 60 and
older and I wanted to figure out why I
apparently something to do with it that
she reminds them of their first wife and
so there's a man we do a focus to a
question where and we asked them to and
I'm gonna ask you all the same question
here you're getting divorced and boy are
you pissed at your spouse man are you
angry and you got a choice of only two
lawyers to hire to sue your spouse
either Bill Clinton or Bob Dole who are
you gonna choose and in every single
focus group people raise their hand and
say Hillary the other question that we
asked and this deals with character and
this is serious and I and I and they
asked Bob Dole the question this is an
actual honest-to-goodness focus-group
question which we've been put out you
just want a free trip to York for you
and your spouse but you got to leave
tonight you got two names to call for a
babysitter you have a 15 year old
daughter young impressionable innocent
which of those two people you're gonna
call nonce a funny question
and they asked Bob Dole because he
mentioned this he repeated the
focus-group response and he responded
very defensively Bob Schieffer on CBS
asked him you know what did you mean by
that well all he had to do was simply
say hey look
there may be a difference in character
between the two individuals running
there maybe I'm not saying there is a
character is a legitimate issue instead
of beating Bill Clinton over the head
with character merely raise the issue
and let the voters themselves male and
female like make the decision look the
way that we're gonna beat the gender gap
quite frankly the way we're going to
close it because again it does exist it
does exist I'm sorry but it is there
understand that is by having more women
running for office in the very fact that
we have as many female members of
Congress two female senators and so many
female lieutenant governor's is an
indication that Republican women have an
advantage but that doesn't answer the
question about how to get elected and I
want to actually give you specific
communication points to try to help in
this process and the first one is I hate
this podium and I hate this microphone
but I know that you've got c-span
cameras that are sitting right there and
if I could I would jump over yank this
thing out and walk among you don't if
you're gonna run for office stand behind
this podium you'll look like a
politician the public hates politicians
I'd rather be a used car salesman right
now than a politician so don't replicate
it that's number one number two is you
got to talk from personal experience
you've heard a lot of numbers up here if
I ever hear someone start talking about
numbers it makes me angry because the
public doesn't understand in terms of
numbers the only one who knows anything
about billions or trillions is Ross
Perot I mean III I admit I admit I'm
sorry I made a mistake I work for him in
1992 he was shorter than I was and that
mattered to me at the time but I'm older
and more mature now so I'm working for
more proper people don't do the numbers
talk in personal experience third is how
does it affect the individual if you go
to top look women have a lead over a man
in talking about welfare you are more
credible when you talk about welfare
when you talk about crime well you talk
about drugs when you talk about
education when you talk about health
care you've got the advantage just by
standing up if it was me if the two of
us were standing
together if Linda and I were standing
together and I asked a general group who
do you think who do you think would
understand more about welfare they would
choose Lind over me they would choose
her with crime you've got the advantage
but we're not drawing the contrast
because women are more likely to talk in
personal experience instead of program
programmatic what does it mean to the
individual to the family that's actually
experiencing the problems number four
use rhetorical questions and I'm going
to ask you all question I hope the
cameras can catch this how many of you
believe that you have a better quality
of life today then your parents did when
they were your age show of hands better
quality your parents your age when they
were your age and how many think it's
worse three people four people in the
whole room think it's worse now tell me
the truth how many of you honestly
believe that your kids will have a
better quality of life than you when
they reach your age but look around look
around three people have their hands up
when all of you believe that you did
better before it's all about
generational improvement that's what the
American Dream is about if you all use
the rhetorical nature if you all ask
these questions your audience will sit
for a minute two minutes five minutes
and they will not forget anything that
you say and when we ask these questions
who's more likely to address it by two
to one they will say that women are more
likely to understand what
intergenerational improvements all about
in the answer the question is why it's
because you all have sacrificed for your
children as my mother sacrificed for me
yeah I wish my mom are watching I did
not realize that this was going to be on
I'll have to tape it so she can see it
because she gave so much to me it is
part of our inherent nature of
understanding the differences between
men and women that when you when you
have the challenge of intergenerational
improvement the public is more likely to
respond to you than they are to a male
and you need to highlight that and
finally don't say that you care
prove that you care I'm tired of
watching Republicans say hey I'm
compassion
I don't work and the public doesn't buy
it you got to prove that you're
compassionate by what you say and what
you do and how you do it if we are to
change if we are to reduce this we have
to find a better way to communicate we
have to find a better way to explain the
hope for eliminating what does exist is
in this room and I'm grateful that
you've taken the time you are not
typical but the very fact that you're
here listening to political speeches and
I apologize that we've gone on for about
45 minutes without interaction because
that's something that the public wants
but the answer the solution to the
gender chasm is in this room and it only
works if you run for office it only
works if you stand up in front of the
media it only works if you stand up and
get counted to complain about it or to
ignore it it will exist and continue to
grow the only way you're going to solve
it is by fighting it and hopefully this
will help you communicate to fight it
because of the Republican Party is the
answer not just for right now but for
the next generation of the next
generation of Americans I thank you very
much
[Applause]
well as you can see it's not just that
women are not a monolith women are not
all alike even Republicans aren't a
monolith Republicans aren't all alike
we've had some fairly significant
disagreement up here about whether there
is or is not a gender gap I'm not sure
that we've had different prescriptions
but it is important which side of that
analysis you come down on we would like
your questions now and what I'd
appreciate is if you ask a question if
you'd stand up and and do what I know
you're all doing out there on the
campaign trail as you work for
yourselves and other candidates speak
forcefully so we can hear you yes please
because my children are always but I
think
their quality of life is so much more
well work hard your job
Linda want you well I think you're
exactly right and what you said I mean
one thing that is true today is that
young people today will probably face
eight different careers or job
opportunities during the course of their
lifetime and even if they feel they are
content in their job today there is that
fear of the future what might happen
five or ten years down the road which
frankly also extends to their children
one of the things we found interesting
in focus group we did in Florida two
years ago was this one one woman said
that her eight-year-old son was no
longer working as hard as he could in
school because he had seen what happened
to his dad who had worked all his life
for this one company and his dad had
been laid off so he said well what's you
know what's in it for me why should I
work this hard in that deep-rooted
insecurities you know taking place in
somebody who's only you know 12 years
old I think sends a certain signal about
people's pessimism about the future
which was underscored in some of the
data I mentioned too earlier and we had
a focus group in Baltimore where some
woman stood up and said hey you know I
keep hearing about Bill Clinton's eight
million new jobs he created I know I
have three of them so you've got a
situation but it's much more than just
jobs quality of life is what are the
kids learning in school if anything what
are you watching on television or seeing
in the movies do you feel safe walking
to your car at night do you feel safe
when you open the door I remember as a
child that coming home from a vacation I
never doubted the idea that my house
would be broken into now here in
Washington when I put my key in just
from coming home from work I'm afraid
that's part of quality of life and
that's something that the Democratic
Party has never ever attempted to solve
and that's something that we got to do
ourselves Kellyanne you have a comment
yes please you've given us some very
good reasons to vote Republican what I
don't understand is why we are not
getting that message out and maybe why
are we not even I know the media won't
get the message out so why are we not
buying advertising or something to get
the message out the second question is
with the recent study of the National
Foundation for women business owners
showing that there are more employees
working for women business owners than
in the fortune 500 companies and
National Federation of Independent
Business just did a study showing that
something like 65 percent of American
households either work for a small
business or are a small business owner
why are we not targeting and really
focusing on the small business owners
and their employees specifically because
I understand with that coalition it is
even larger than the Christian Coalition
is a voting bloc yes easily I'll go and
reverse order first to the Small
Business Center I think on every
Republican may want to start a speech or
a conversation with the following that
the Republican Party welcomes everyone
it is a party of three main groups the
American family the middle class
taxpayer and the small business owner or
employee and I've challenged multiple
numbers of people in focus groups to
tell me is there do you feel like you do
not fit in any of those categories is
there one missing is there another one
that should be on there everyone feels
like they're at least one if not two of
not three within that category and we've
tested them as pollster so we know that
they're all properly sanitized
middle-class tax payers fine Americans
family is fine you could define family
as you want but the small business owner
employee is an interesting one because
there are now 21 million small
businesses in our country 7.7 million of
them as
this January were owned by women and
you're absolutely correct that they
employ more now than all fortune 500
companies combined I do believe the
Republican Party is targeting them as
that goes I do think that women like
small business owners are tired of being
targeted and just want to be talked to
and talked with and not so targeted but
the difficulty is that small business is
never able to organize itself as a
cohesive voting bloc the way the labor
unions are or some areas of big business
this is because of the issues that
galvanize them they're high tax burden
the high regulatory burden you're
looking at three small business owners
right up here as pollsters and I can
tell you that in starting a company the
number one thing is not wondering where
your clients are come from or who to
employ it's wondering where you're going
to find the time to comply with all of
these regulatory burdens and hiring
accountants and outside experts that is
a message that hinges on to what Frank
Luntz was saying that to personalize
things means come out and talk as a
mother come out and talk as a small
business owner a talk is a daughter
who's concerned that Medicare is going
to go bankrupt and you may be stuck with
the we all talk about the horizontal
squeeze but this is the vertical squeeze
paying for college tuitions for your
children and caring for an elderly
parent when you weren't counting on
doing that and this is something I think
we should rest a little more comfortably
small business owners and employees do
vote more Republican the Democrat the
RNC I know is very attuned to that fact
and I let my colleagues respond if they
want but quickly as to your first
question about why we don't buy time on
to some degree and this is an
oversimplification we're broke
that's as compared to the Clinton
administration Bill Clinton will get 12
million dollars in taxpayer money this
year to help him defeat Bob Dole there's
a message that we all should be getting
out there's something that I bet none of
us want to pay for and I think as time
goes on the dole campaign in conjunction
with the Republican Party nationally
statewide and locally will be able to
buy more time but strategically if
people aren't concentrating on the
election in large numbers now it doesn't
make a lot of sense to get the message
out in every in every local station
now but I think it will comment the
convention matters a lot people still
remember the convention from 1992 some
of their impressions of the party came
from that convention four years ago and
stay with them that's the free media
time we should all take advantage of how
many women did you see in that budget
during the budget negotiations on the
Republican side I saw Laura Tyson and I
saw Donna shillelagh on TV constantly on
the three networks and I didn't see one
woman on the Republican side I watched
these press conferences and I work for
these House and Senate leaders and they
are my heroes but with all due respect
to them when you watch them at the
center press gallery in the house press
gallery if we're even lucky there'll be
11 men and one woman kind of trying to
angle her way to get into the shot it's
horrible and it looks horrible and it
sends a message and so again to say well
you know we'll ignore the problem you
want to know why the message isn't
getting out because we're not putting
out the message there have to be more
women in leadership but that means that
women have got to run for leadership
they're not going to get appointed I
don't know if Jennifer Dunn is still in
here but I think that that I'm hoping
that she either goes for the Senate in
Washington or runs for a higher position
in the house
same thing with Debra price same thing
with kay Bailey Hutchinson and what
she's doing over on the Senate side you
got to go for it you got to take it
because no one's going to give it to you
but the more that you fight for it the
more that you take it the better off
it's going to be for all of us
I do think Frank I'm sorry I'm supposed
to be an impartial moderator here but I
do think it is very important
particularly since we have this c-span
audience that we emphasize how the
Republican leadership in the house has
promoted women to levels that the
Democrats never did that is very
important it is also important that we
get them in the front row at the news
conferences that is the communication is
important as the reality is as well
other questions yes way in the back I
think you don't really bring it down to
them look to their level personally and
how can we do that because they're
interested in how does that help my
family what does that do for me and I
had one person say to me if balancing
the budget is the most important thing
you're running on I think you're wrong
and and of course I think the voter was
wrong and I tried to explain so maybe we
can get some comments on that what a
good question that's well I think all
three of us have spent time with House
and Senate leaders trying to get them to
personalize what balancing the budget
means and my best example of this is to
try to say what does it mean to the
family of four with two young children
when they're starting their family when
they're worried about college tuition
cost 20 years down the road what does it
mean to the single woman or divorce or
widowed woman who's 65 years of age
living on a fixed income and what does
it say to a young small businessperson
perhaps a woman who's starting a
dry-cleaning company what a balanced
budget means to her we talk too much
about you know deficit reduction and we
talked too much about policy and process
as opposed to particular izing what it
means you know just look at a
kellyanne's segmentation of the
middle-class taxpayer etc we need to do
more of that of talking directly to
families the speaker frankly made a very
good start at that last May I think we
need to get back on that track too often
we become the green eyeshade Republicans
and don't personalize what what's at
stake is for families and particularly
the small business owner when you look
at the regulatory tax burden when you
look at the paperwork just when you look
at you know taxes overall I mean I
remember starting my business and the
first question by the
city of Alexandria was estimate your
income so that we can charge you right
now for the taxes you must pay so I said
you know the heck with you zero but it's
that type of type of thing that
Republicans need to do a much better job
of personalizing the stake in defining
what it means to Americans one of the
real advantages of how I say this middle
age is you get grandchildren I now have
a granddaughter who is two and I would
bet that for a lot of you who are at
this stage of life to that grandchild
brings home these issues in a way that
nothing else does and we've got a little
time to think about a little time to be
philosophical about it and I have to
tell you I talk about my granddaughter
because I care I care if 80% of her
wages will go to the government if we do
not fix the budget if we do not fix
Medicare if we do not fix the Social
Security system I care about that when
you talk about your own kids your own
grandkids that's when I find a real
response to the people I'm talking to
can I just I want to give you four
specific examples you talked about
thinking of parents with children in
high school afraid that their children
won't be able to attend the College of
their choice because they cannot afford
the interest on the loans you talk about
the newly married couple that wants to
buy a piece of the American Dream a home
but can't afford the mortgage rates you
talk of the couples in their 40s and 50s
who are desperately trying to do the
right thing and save for the future by
the way for those of you who are baby
boomers in this audience you're in deep
trouble the government taxes you double
and triple x on your savings and on your
investments and so you don't save and
you don't invest and you're not prepared
for retirement
because if the government is going to
spend all the money why shouldn't we all
the government sets the example and
finally you talk about your parents and
your grandparents who are depending on
Medicare but are afraid it won't be
there when they will need it that
involves everyone from every age group
and the budget affects people personally
bluh
hile and i would like to say that I
agree with the women of the gentleman up
there that said we need to get the word
out that there are women in the
Republican Party I'm an elected official
from Ohio we have a woman lieutenant
governor a woman Attorney General and a
woman Speaker of the House so we need to
get that message out that in Ohio no
other state we're electing Republican
women and the other thing about eligible
women to vote and we know women have
wealth but how are we going to get those
women to the polls and those women to be
spending where I'm standing right now
because we know the numbers are there
how are we going to take that next step
well first of all we have to demonstrate
to women that they have a stake and what
happens in terms of policy and politics
and again just answering the question on
balanced budget the more we can
personalize what that stake means to
them the better off we are the more that
they understand that Republican Party
does indeed help women and give them
opportunities particularly in campaigns
in the Republican Party for 20 years has
been excellent in this regard in terms
of campaign management health financial
help you know writing of campaign plans
but again as Frank said until we get
more women to run and and I think women
also want to make certain that they are
more assured of their success they want
to know that the finance is there they
want to know that there will be key key
supporters of theirs within the
community because nobody wants to put
their their name on the ballot and be
embarrassed and lose but I think you are
seeing a very aggressive job at the
Republican National Committee with the
co-chairs office at the NRCC and with
many of these state parties to do
everything they can to get women to run
for office because the primary thing
that many of us have discovered over the
years is that women help turn around the
stereotype that many people have with
the Republican Party and anytime you can
you know negate some of those
stereotypes
you are indeed putting a different face
on the party we've got one great heroine
in the Republican Party I don't know if
she has spoken to you or will speak to
you the person who I think has done more
to help people in states like Ohio
that's Evelyn MacPhail who's co-chairman
to answer your question in one sentence
if we could clone Evelyn MacPhail and
create 50 of her we would not have this
problem the fact is we would not need to
meet here again or if we did we'd have
to take the entire hotel if we could
just clone 50 of her just quickly I
certainly agree on the comment about
Evelyn I I think that we should be
hardened by the fact that if I had a if
I had to advise us on how to get more
women into the Republican fold I'd say
in terms of message messenger and
delivery the the the traditional tough
work is done because most in most
American women agree with our message if
you have a blind poll question as I call
it where you say I'm now going to give
you two solutions to the welfare debate
to the crime debate health care and you
just say here's solution one here
solution to most women go for the
Republican solution and you could take
the solutions right out of speeches you
can take them right out of legislation
but later in the same poll if you
identify it as a Republican and Democrat
the numbers change women bolt from the
label so we need to work on the
messenger and the delivery style by
messenger I mean we always try to be the
honest party of solutions of ideas and
without abandoning that recognize that
it needs to be finessed style needs to
be added I think for example Bob Dole
gets off of the Bob Dole for president
campaign plan plane and he's greeted by
seven white men and navy suits and
that's a very honest entourage to be
greeting him four of them were probably
with the Secret Service but the fact is
that Bill Clinton comes off Air Force
One and he gives that famous look that
none of us can imitate them and he's
greeted by two of those men two women an
African American and Hispanic someone in
a wheelchair I mean it's really it's
it's very much pandering but the fact is
that staging that's right the fact is
that we are such a busy society and
women with our two workplaces are among
the busiest that we often not only lose
the soundbite war to the Democrats but
we lose the visual bite war because
right now six
outside the election so many women are
getting their information like that and
you see a vision and I would say the
first way to turn those women around and
bring them into the Republican Party is
to give them symbols and messengers to
whom they can relate seeing is believing
one last question there is somebody back
in a blue suit who's had her hand up
first many times thank you very much for
allowing me to even stand and make a
presentation I would agree very
wholeheartedly with I send to Howard
that is definitely a message that has to
be gotten out I ran for public office I
defeated four Democrats
and you are right on target you have to
make it personal and I'd like to share
with you what I said I talked to the
audience and I said work hard and I've
done that I said act right and I've done
that and believe in God and good things
will happen I did that and ladies and
gentlemen it is wonderful to be here to
share with you the opportunity that I
had and I am going to go back revitalize
and get a message because believe me I
wear 2x and I'm not gonna tell you what
those two heads are you can decide on
what they are I have a message and I
have a mission and I'm gonna do
everything that I can to make Bob Dole
our next president of the United States
well I can't top that I should probably
just ask everyone's walk off the stage
at this point but I will have to just
add one little bit of advice to any of
the Republican organizers of our
convention that might be listening one
of the ways to accomplish what the three
people up here have said today about
making the many many women who are
active and successful in Republican
politics visible